[Music]
since the Super Bowl is this Sunday I
thought once again would bring out our
own sports handicapping animal she
helped us predict successfully the World
Series last year she is back tonight
please welcome chickpea the super bowl
predicting chicken let's get around
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right this is chickpea she's a
real chicken and just play along all
right we don't have HGTV she's a real
chicken on either side of her of her pen
is the Seahawks helmet and a Patriots
helmet filled with chicken feet
whichever helmet she eats out of is the
team she thinks will win the Super Bowl
let's see what she does okay
moving towards the Seahawks so maybe
gonna pick the Seahawks hold it to the
wait a minute the changing direction
talk walking strangely towards the
Patriots helmet maybe gonna pick the hit
wait a minute thinking thinking
chickpeas says she has has a plan
presentation she was like she goes she's
freaking but the Seahawks is seven and
to the Belichick is 20 and eight in the
playoffs with the Patriots wing not
attached chicken the weather for the
Super Bowl in Phoenix is going to be
around 73 degrees this slide compares
the total QPR rating for both starting
quarterbacks now the chickpea is showing
us a bunch of football play diagrams
they don't really know how to read those
now if she's talking about deflategate
she's off on that one okay now these are
just vacation photos
come on you're just showing us
no stop no
[Applause]
come on just make your pick chickpea
make your pick come on God's sake
ridiculous Patriots
[Applause]
you